hey there do you ever come across a
motion design piece that blows you away
and you wonder how it was made well
here's a quick tip to help you learn
from the pros study and dissect the work
that inspires you frame by frame pay
attention to the small details the
timing the pacing and the transitions
try to break it down and understand how
the design elements come together to
create a cohesive Hole by doing this
you'll not only gain a deeper
appreciation for the craft of motion
design but you'll also learn valuable
techniques and approaches that you can
apply to your own work so pay attention
to the details and study the Masters and
who knows you might just become one
yourself